what's up I saw you play war zone how'd
you know that it's online everyone's
talking about the amazing play from the
Lee brothers so right so what I realized
that number one bad in a war real-life
and get this is essentially what it's
line oh you hate this babe hmm
essentially what every games like okay
this is Eric Griffin all right meet me
by the tree what tree the tree
[Music]
Steve guys guys I don't know where I'm
at where are you he's on the other side
of the [ __ ] map he parachuted the
other side of the map and then at the
end of the game zero kills every [ __ ]
time yeah it's a terror it's a terrible
I don't know why though I like it though
it's stressful it's very stressed it's
very stressful but fun so last night I
was playing do you have the video or do
you want to hey I think I might have
just sent it to George dannis on video
to George so I'm playing with my brother
and um Erik last night and you know I
have my headphones on I'm in the garage
he's five hours the he's five hours in a
war zone three hours lot no no wasn't
you started at 10:45 and this was at
3:00 midnight he didn't start at
midnight you were down there much longer
they were there only reason that I went
downstairs to to check on you was
because I had texted you because I
hadn't heard a peep in hours and I
thought is he okay yeah I mean okay I
was dying so what I did was I went to I
walked downstairs to go check on you and
you know that's that's what happens when
I check on you so she me show the video
she's this is the garage and I'm playing
I didn't sneak in it was I fight I
opened the door like a normal person
I wasn't creeping in right
and so that she she's now taping me from
behind
good I don't know any I don't know that
it was in the [ __ ] garage and I'll
turn around and that sounded I made
maybe laughs so [ __ ] much
it's I'm number what I'm a [ __ ] that
sounded show the video but that sound
that I made that's a good setup though
yeah did you hear they do you guys hear
sound on that I can hear online we have
to edit it in I want to say one thing
before we continue is this on are we re
on George